hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar dissecting the tumor
micro-environment
part 1 tools for isolation and flow
analysis
I am sorry grandma of lab roots and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab Rouge the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by milton e biotech
for almost 30 years
Milton E biotech has played an important
role in the design development
manufacture and integration of products
that empower the advancement of
biomedical research and enable cell and
gene therapy let's get started
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop-down box located on
the far left of your screen label to ask
a question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
hearing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Olaf
Hart manager of R&D oncology at Milton E
biotech dr. Olive heart obtained his PhD
at the University of Cologne Germany and
collaboration with Milton EVO Tech and
the IBD ml in Marseille France before he
started as R&D project manager at Milton
E biotech in 2008 in his current
position as manager
R&D on ecology from Milton e-value tech
in Burgas gal Vox Germany he focuses on
immuno oncology preclinical research
target discovery as well as oncology
related product development he also had
the transgenic unit and animal facility
dr. heart will now begin his
presentation
thank you very much for this kind of
induction and thanks to all of you for
joining today to learn more about the
dissociation and isolation of solid
tumor cells faulty mice downstream
analysis so now you can see the agenda
of this talk today I want to start with
the dissociation of solid tissues that
is really one important prerequisite for
all the things I will show you
downstream of that then I want to focus
on the isolation of tumor cells and
subpopulations there and that will be
the major part of this webinar and
lastly it will also discuss briefly the
isolation of till however there will be
also a colleague of mine giving a
seminar in particular on this topic so
here you can see the cancer research
workflow that we have developed of the
past couple of years that Melanie and
you see is really starting with the
solid tissue where we have optimized and
developed a max 2 to storage solution
which I will not discuss today it's
already pretty well established in the
market I mean the aim of this 3d if you
have your tissues and you cannot process
them right away but you have for example
to store them overnight or over the
weekend or if you want to ship them to
another side for processing as we
frequently do it actually in-house then
you can use this tissue storage solution
to store your tissue prior for it to
dissociation and downstream processing
then the next step is of course the
sample preparation so getting a single
cell suspension from your solid tumor
tissue or any other kind of tissue and
for this I will discuss the most each
tumor Association kits today and then
following this when you have your viable
single cell suspension you can go on for
set isolation to really isolate the
target cells that you interested in to
then go on for any kind of further
downstream analysis molecular culture
whatever you want to do so let's start
with some preparation aspect and you
know that politicians are the lab of a
mixture of cells that are linked by cell
adhesion molecules XSL matrix
basal membranes so you have two
principle goals the first one is of
course very obvious so you want to
disrupt the EXO telemachus and cell
adhesion components without destroying
the integrity of the cell membrane and
for this usually enzymatic
is the way to go however there's also
second goal that is not so obvious and
not considered during many dissociation
procedures and that is that you might
want to preserve your cell surface
epitopes for example if you want to
isolate your cells have of choice based
on their surface marks you want to do
flow analysis but even if you want to do
function as and you need the cell
surface receptor such as the growth
factor receptors intact then of course
mechanical disruption is the way to go
however a combination of both mechanical
and enzymatic treatment is usually
optimal for efficient dissociation and
that is what we have really optimized
for a couple of years to bring out the
optimal enzyme combinations as shown
here the tumor dissociation kit which is
composed of a mixture of three highly
purified enzymes to reduce the lot alert
variation that you can get if you use
for example bulky enzymes that still
have triptych emo triptych background
activities like a lot of collagen aids
actually have and this we combined with
optimized and user independent
mechanical disruption by our gentle max
[ __ ] agent mix instrument in
combination with our cube based system
and actually to learn a little bit more
about your application we would like to
answer you a poll that will just come up
right now
you
you
okay before I really go into the details
of tissue dissociation I would also do a
short ex course let's say and tell you a
little bit about the tips and tricks
that we have learned over the last
couple of years when working with
dissociated politicians in particular
tumor tissues because they are actually
quite different to hem aerobic tissues
like PBMC or bone marrow and you will
see a lot of doctors during my
presentation so I want to make sure that
you really can follow what I'm using
them for and what are the particular
things I want to point out and on this
slide you see that in contrast to many
other like cell lines or PBMC there's a
significant heterogeneity in dissociated
tumor so here you see three different
examples of a dissociated tumor tissue
and you'll see they also look very very
different among each other nests of
course depends on the tumor types but
also varies from patient to patient and
therefore what we are using is usually a
lot of best gating and as you can see
here on this slide so we identify the
major lineages such as the red blood
cells white blood cells by known markers
and then we gate back these markers as
shown here in red and blue for example
and in green for tumor cells and on the
right hand side you see the forward side
scalar gates and then you see where
these populations are actually located
in a dot plot and then you can draw the
the gate the initial gate in the forward
side SCADA dot plot based on the red
blood cells because they would be the
small cells and then therefore you are
not at risk of cutting out any relevant
cell types however what you also see is
that depending on the two different
tumors that you see here the up and the
lower panel the composition is very
different so when you try to get out red
blood cells just by foresight delegating
you might lose red blood air you might
lose also other nucleated cells so
therefore usually we don't do that we
just get out papers and then we get out
of red blood cells by size of it markers
as you can see here here in human system
that would be like for an a animal
system it would be ter 119 and then as
you see here in the lower left panel you
can also combine this with propidium
iodide for cell viability
the dead cells and red blood cells out
and then you can get an accurate
accounting of your nucleated cells and
you created cell subpopulations
so
a question that we are frequently asked
is why we use the logarithmic scale in
the forward side scatter plots and that
is pretty pretty specific to solid
tissues I would say and here's the
reason why as you can see in the upper
left dot dot here we associated a casino
graph and we stained the human fm+ cells
and the mouse here on him all fits
positive cells and engaged them back in
blue and in red into the forward side
scatter gait so you see the red arrow
marks the small Mouse cells the blue
arrow marks a large tumor cells and then
in a lower panel you see in the hyper
loop that looks pretty nice it's a nice
resolution you can see all these
populations if you know transform that
will do great mix three scale then you
already see okay that's getting pretty
broad and you can still resolve the
tumor cells the human tumor cells in the
mouse cells but the difference is
already in the only access on the sub
channel and then if you even go to the
linear scale which most people use when
using hematopoietic tissues you see you
can now resolve the DeVries lower left
and then the red mouse cells but the
human tumor cells they are so different
in size that they are already under some
Shinzon the X's on the right and then on
the upper part of course you can also
decrease the detector laser power to
bring the tumor cells back into the gate
but then you will not be able to
distinguish between the mouse cells and
the dippers so we really prefer the high
full of rhythmic scale in order to get a
good resolution of this very
heterogeneous tissues and a large aspect
of particular pitfalls when working with
dissociated tumor samples is that a
tumor cells after dissociation can be
very sticky and that is a problem of
course if you work with like debt
service such as propidium iodide
so you see here an unstained upper
left-hand sample everything is okay then
you set the gate you standard with
propidium iodide to label dead cells it
should only be included in dead cells
but actually you see oh wow only 30%
viability so that looks pretty bad if
you combine that with an antibody such
as C D 24 PE which not labels to tumor
cells you still see about 30% viability
however now if you stained
tumor cells by npe antibody like f kin
PE in the lower right hand side you
clearly see that you have two
populations of viable or three
populations viable but also two
populations of dead cells the left left
population in the upper gate you see
these are the dead non tumor cells and
to really lower left the population
these are the viable non tumor cells but
you see in F chem labeled the big wrong
population these are actually the viable
tumor cells and about there there is a
smaller additional population and now
you'll see these are the dead tumor
cells but if you would not use both
dimensions here but just the one let's
say the diagonal you can never see where
you should set the gate so just to keep
it in mind be careful when you exclude
viable and dead cells when working with
dissociated samples so all this
knowledge of course we apply then in
analyzing and optimizing our
dissociation procedures in order to of
course get a good viability and a good
yield after dissociation but also we do
a lot of function is we do cell culture
of the cells as you see here in the in
the bottom panel for example is a human
melanoma cultured after two days and
then after ten days when I see the
melanoma colonies are growing on on a
layer of fiberglass that is it would be
expected so there's all concerning the
first question that you have containing
the second one the epitope preservation
we really spend a lot of time to analyze
that and it's shown here how we do it we
take PBMCs or other blood cells and cell
lines and then we label them with cell
surface markers and treat them with the
enzymes that we use for this sociation
and then we check the expression level
so in flow cytometry system in
fluorescence intensity to actually check
if the expression level of this marker
is altered by the enzyme set to use
which is not the case for these three
markers but of course there are many
more markers and it's why we do whole
sets of its marker screenings and we
shake all of these markers in the
portfolio Mallis and the idea behind
that is really that the research is
doing an experiment planning an
experiment and designing their panels
can look beforehand if they are markers
SS survey
epitopes will be affected by the enzyme
and not learn it the hard way by just
seeing all my step populations gone I
cannot detect it anymore so you can just
download this list from our webpage and
then you can design your panels based on
this and as you see only about 5% of the
markets are actually affected by our
enzyme composition when you compare this
to trypsin or other very aggressive
enzymes active States or papaya in
usually more than 50% of the epitopes
are affected and because we use this
mixture of three highly purified enzymes
but they are solely tagged you can see
by reducing enzyme are almost all of
these markers can be preserved and it's
only you buy and of course buy a little
bit lower yield and viability of the
very tightly connected cells like tumor
cells and the endothelial cells which
are closely connected but if you are
analyzing immune markers that might be
the method of choice actually
so this is also seen of course in a lot
of other applications and this is for
example from one of our collaboration
partners David killed him who was a dead
time based in Manchester and working on
two men filtrating lymphocytes from
renal cell carcinoma and what you can
see here on the left hand side is the
comparison of our gentle mix tumor
dissociation kit digestion as compared
to the published overnight digestion
only with collagenase but again as I
mentioned collagen ages frequently have
unspecific triptych and human triptych
activities you'll see during this
incubation with overnight digest you
lose the cd4 and cd8 signal while you
can nicely depict populations in our
dissociation kit and model moreover also
because of their very gentle
dissociation procedure you see that the
functionality of the set is actually
significantly improved so by culturing
the isolated tilts with autologous tumor
cells from these patients you see that
here by redoubted from gamma release by
these co-cultures the t-cell activation
is much better with our procedure than
with the classical overnight digest
just as a side note next to the human to
meditation kit which is used for the
dissociation of human tumors so
everything that comes directly out of a
human but also of xenograft so human
tumor growing in a mouse we also have a
mouse too much Association kit which is
optimized towards the dissociation of
Sinjin eggs grafted mouse tumors but
also genetically induced mouth tumors
and basically the same applies here and
also for this we have epitope
preservation list of course then for the
marine epitopes so if you're working
with engineered mouse models for example
in immune Oncology you can design your
panels based on these stability data so
the last aspect concerning dissociation
of this viable tissue is actually pretty
surprising because there are always some
approaches to do a tissue dissociation
purely on a mechanical basis in order to
avoid any epitope stability issues so
meaning that when you do not use enzyme
the enzyme cannot harm your epitopes
however what we figured out actually a
colleague of mine working with tilts for
many years now it is possible to
dissociate some tumors so the very soft
ones like b16 Mouse melanomas without
enzymes and you of course get a lower
yield and viability of the tumor cells
and etherion cells again a very tightly
connected tissue cells however the cd45
so the overall two counts look pretty
normal
however if you now look really at a very
specific t-cells such as the Tim three
positive pd-1 positive like three
positives tumor active T cells which are
tightly connected to the tumor cells you
see with our gentle mixed procedure and
the tumor Association case you get a
very nice
population in the in the upper panel if
you use a pure mechanical dissociation
you completely lose this population not
because of epitope preservation issues
but just because these cells are lost
because of the mechanical stress
so in just a small side note this was on
our dissociation of viable tissues you
know I've also recently released a
method for dissociation and getting a
single cell suspension order for my
lipsticks paraffin-embedded tissues
which you then can use for floor sorting
for some for isolation of the tumor
cells flow analysis and also DNA
downstream analysis and my colleague
Bastian will also give a very in our
beginning of tune on exactly this tissue
so if you're working with sspe tissue
please join webinar and learn more about
this very novel application
so with this I want to finish with the
sample preparation part and now go on
for the set isolation now you have your
viable single cell suspension in a good
shape and now you can isolate your
target cells and of course that Milton
II we mostly focus on magnetic
separation most of you might know the
system I will briefly explain it the
printer is rather easy so you start with
the heterogeneous cell composition
showing in the left hand side and n
views and he bodies that are specific
towards the epitope of your target cell
that are coupled to paramagnetic
nanoparticles very small ones like 50
nanometers it's the size of the virus
and therefore also guarantees that the
cells are not affected by this and then
we run it over a column that is placing
in magnetic fields the non-labor cells
are just in a flow through friction if
you remove the column from the magnetic
fields you can elude your target cells
and of course it's also possible vice
versa if you do not know an epitope of
your target cell or if you do not want
to touch your target cell with an
antibody you can also label the non
target cells and they will stay in the
column and your target says then of
course will be in a flow through
friction and the methods I will show you
right now are all based actually on
these untouched or we call it negative
selection approaches
so let's talk about now the isolation of
untouched tumor cells in principle there
are three major starting materials where
you can isolate tumor cells from
xenograft the tumors to human tumors
growing in a mouse pure Mouse tumors
mouse
tumors growing in a mouse setting and of
course primary human tumors and for all
of these tumors we have developed
optimized methods for dissociation and
also for isolation of the cells which I
will show you now I will go more into
detail for the casino graph the tumors
now because the principle in a method
are very comparable among all of these
so let's focus on a casino customer
first of all we have to ask ourselves
why should I
deplete the mouse cells out of a clean
graph tumor is it important or not and
of course if it always depends on the
downstream application but what you can
see here is three different models of
non-small cell lung cancer in rats and
mice and you see the degree of mouth
selling situation is very different
among the different patient tumors
however when you graph two tumors in
each flank or in both flanks of the mice
you see that even these two tumors which
coming from the same patient tumor
have a very heterogeneous degree of
infiltration so if you would do for
example the molecular analysis out of
this you would have a very influential
bias towards the number of infiltrating
mouth cells for your downstream and cell
culture molecular Ennis waste and
rotting everything you you want to
normalize your actually your target
cells towards the starting material
and for this we have come up with a
solution some years ago by doing large
cell surface marker screenings we tested
a couple of hundred antibodies on all
different mouse strains all different
mouths tissues and figured out a
combination of now actually five
antibodies that label all of the mouse's
from all the different organs from all
the different mouse strains so after
you're having dissociated your tissue
you have your single cell suspension you
just add this cocktail of five
antibodies that are coupled to magnetic
particles incubated for 15 minutes you
run it over a column and your human
tumor cells are flowing through the
column if you want you can remove the
column a needle to your mouth cells but
as this is a negative approach it works
for any kind of human tumor cell or even
non tumor cells so any kind of human
said that you graft into a mouse can be
isolated by this procedure and the whole
procedure just takes about 20 minutes
and in a lower panel you can see the
example so you have two F kin positive
human tumor cells and the fm- mouse
cells and then after 20 minutes you have
a pure fraction negative in a negative
fraction of tumor cells and this is as I
said independent on any kind of positive
marker so it works for any kind of solid
tumors like your renal lung and bladder
contracts in graphs but it also works
for leukemias lymphomas and also even
known tumor cells as I will also show
you in a couple of minutes
of course it makes a big difference in
in culture and a frequently seen graphs
like she used to expand the human tumor
material in order then to dissociated
and to generate cell cultures for drug
testing and if you just associated your
casino graph then you put it in a
culture plate it looks like the
dependent I'm showing you right now so
you have image in positive Mouse
fibroblasts and you have for examining
video using a carcinoma fk+ human tumor
cells however if you now do a drug
toxicity essay on this year it would be
very hard to distinguish which effects
come from your target cell and which
from your contaminating cell fractions
by using just this 20-minute multi
removal fraction method you then have
your isolated tumor cells and are barely
any Mouse cells left in the fraction and
now of course you can do a very
homogeneous readout
and what was pretty surprising to us
also next to removing all the mouth
cells one of our initial test sites
actually sig figured out that you also
remove the vast majority of the dead
sets in the D Bruce and its data from
Jeremy rich from the Cleveland Clinic
his group is working on human
glioblastoma cells which they attack
with PSP and then Auto topically
transplant them into Mouse brains and if
you transplant that into a mouse brain
and if you then dissociate an adult
mouse brain most of the things that's
you or events you will have later on
actually breathe and dead cells because
of all the myelin that you destroy doing
the dissociation so you see an a that
the cells only make a minor fraction of
the dissociation and then of course NB
you see the human tumor cell content and
now what you see is that the next two
isolating or depleting all the mouse
cells is also and see that you have
really cleaned up your samples you have
a significantly lower amount of dead
sets and a breeze and this is a very
surprising and of course very beneficial
for a lot of downstream applications
including for example next-generation
sequencing as you see here because we
want to evaluate the Deborah's removal
step also on this in this respect and
did it in collaboration with Charles
River on three different kind of cynnwys
lung kidney and bladder contacts in
rafts and what you can see here is
really that you get a significant
improvement of your sequencing results
so high a cluster density higher year
then therefore also higher read counts
so you really improve that data because
you start with a really higher quality
sample in the beginning
and x2 of course doing that on on pure
blessed to more tissue you can also look
for circulating tumor cells or
disadvantage to myself and it's just one
example example data of the muscle more
mobile lab from from Italy which are
looking in to disseminated tumor cells
so they they set a chain of rafts in an
animal and then after a couple of weeks
they look for human disseminated cells
into the month long for metastatic
spread and if you then take out the lung
and you dissociated usually the human
events are so rare that it's really
below the detection level of flow
cytometry to to enumerate them however
if you now do the master depletion
before then you can significantly rich
it by several doctor heads as you see
here in this example one human cell in
almost three hundred forty thousand
mouths cells whereas us one after the
depletion one human cell in four hundred
mouths sets which is now at a level
where you can really intermarriage it by
flow cytometry and the same holds true
for human circulating tumor cells in
Cocina grafts of course
so last example for for the
emulsification kids is what I mentioned
in the beginning that it's not only
working for tumor tissue but also for a
non tumor tissue because it's marker
independent and this is data from John
Digges lab in Toronto Canada which are
using this kit actually for humanized
mice today do a human him Arabic stem
cell transplantation either from
umbilical cord blood or from a ll bone
marrow and then so they reconstitute the
bone marrow of the mice is a human
immune system and then after a couple of
weeks of course you have a very
heterogeneous chimerism drafting and
then they want to homogenize the Sambas
before they go on with the downstream
analysis and this is what you see in the
right here the black bars are just
before the dictation very heterogeneous
sound composition and in after mouth
cell depletion you nicely normalize all
the samples and then kogo can go on and
reduce this let's say cause of
irreducibility just before you are down
to minute
so I could not go into further molecular
analysis due to time reasons but if
you're interested in that we have some
scientific posters available which you
can download from the web page or just
drop us an email and then we can send
you the posters in particular on the NGS
aspect of math education
the next I want to discuss the isolation
of mouse tumor cells from primary Mouse
tumors and the principle as I mentioned
is completely the same however here the
challenge is more that is of course
harder to find suitable marker because
here you cannot use species specific
antibodies us your target cells a mouse
and also your contaminating cells almost
but again we were able to identify a
market composition in a large cell
surface market screening to now
efficiently isolate also primary or
genetically induced mouth tumor cells
and this is shown here for three
frequently used models the p226 p 16 and
41 tumors and we have text these tumor
cells with GSP before transplantation
into the animals to really attract them
and what you can see here again is the
depletion approach takes only 20 minutes
and you end up with very few isolated
tumor cells and the same was true of
course in the culture when you played
the original infection you see a mixture
of GSP positive tumor cells and smooth
non selecting expressing activated
fibroblasts after dissociation and after
isolation you see very nice and pure
cultures of the isolated tumor cells
the last aspect years of this part is
the isolation of human tumor cells
straight out of patient material and
again I have to say the principle is the
same as the 20-minute procedure that is
based just on the depletion of your
unwanted says it's completely
independent on your markers and what you
can see here this is an original
fraction from a breast cancer patient
you see the fourth side skater again
very high heterogeneity you see a lot of
white blood cells thereby cd45 red that
says like look like Rene and you serious
LCD 31 positive fibroblast and also the
fm+ tumor cells you apply the labeling
neurons over column 20 minutes later you
have a pure human tumor cell fraction
and again if you compare the culture of
these cells you see if you play the
original fraction you see compared to
the to the other starting material to
see tumor cell colonies seen in FM and a
lot of fibroblasts that are also giving
you a high risk of losing this culture
because the fabric they played
efficiently they grow very fast and
frequently you lose the culture by over
growing fiberglass whereas when you
played the cells after
isolation you will have a very nice and
homogeneous culture and you completely
ward the risk of losing your culture by
over growing fiberglass and of course
also if you want to do drug type drug
toxicity again that will be a much more
homogeneous starting population
but it's very important that it does not
only work with let's say easy Sambas
where you already have a high initial
content of tumor cells but it also works
with challenging samples such as a
pleural effusion or fetus and what you
can see here this is a profusion from
ovarian carcinoma patient and you see
the two more content and slam it here by
FM staining is very low it's usually
below 1% in pleural effusions
but again applying the same procedure to
any minute after you have a very pure
population of your tumor cells that you
can now go into culture or do molecular
needs or whatever you want to do and
this is from the very same patient we
plated the original infection let it
adhere and and grow for 3 days and then
we washed it several times with CBS then
you see in the contrast okay there are
some tumor cells in there but there are
also a lot of other cells and debris is
five of last blood cells whereas when
you just isolate the cells and place
them very same patient but this time
without washing with PBS you see a very
nice and homogeneous tumor cell cultures
you see a lot of multinucleated cells
which is a hallmark of a variant
carcinoma and of course you can then go
on and expand these cells for further
analysis
so we were wondering what is the
influence of the isolation of the tumor
cells on next-generation sequencing
because this is one of the major
applications that people are doing right
now so what we have done is we received
tumors we associated them based on a
tumor dissociation kit isolated tumor
cells and also the stromal cells and
immediate exome sequencing on the
Illumina platform on the isolated tumor
cells and on so on the bias tumor which
is currently the most frequently used
method so you just take a chunk of tumor
you lies it isolate DNA or RNA and then
you do the sequencing
and what you can see here is the loss of
heterozygosity from two different
ovarian carcinomas Vonn ovarian
carcinoma metastasis and also on to
moment and what you can see is that you
have a much more accurate detection of
the loss of heterozygosity events in the
isolated tumor cells because you do not
have to contaminate in DNA from all the
other non tumor cells such as white
blood cells and the fiberglass and
ethereal cells in the five tumor samples
and this you can of course also see in
the mutation calling so this is a
mutation in the p53 gene and this
ovarian carcinoma patient and also the
in a primary human in the metastasis and
when you just sequence the BIOS to map
shown here in blue you'll see okay that
looks like a heterozygous loss of
function in p53 but as we know from the
flow analysis there was about 50% tumor
cell content in these samples and we
know okay actually that's coming from
the impurity of sample so after
isolating the tumor cells you actually
see is it's a homozygous loss of
function mutation in this p53 and this
of course is not so challenging because
the tumor cell content was high and we
are looking for clonal mutations but if
you now look at low tumor cell content
and sub-clonal mutations you're really
going into the detection limit and this
is shown here when we isolate the to
moment which is usually as a to mome of
the carcinomas assignments where after
dissociation you have usually less than
1 or 2 percent tumor cells in your in
your fraction and if your sequence these
you see here in on panel 8 this is a
proto-oncogene ik gene better cutting in
one version and when just sequencing
device tumor you do not detect any
mutation and reads as you can see here
in the in the gray shaped area whereas
when we isolate the tumor cells to about
90% we actually see there's a
heterozygous loss of function as Rho
zygous gain-of-function in this tumor
and even more prominent I think is the
example here in beef where by sequencing
the bio 2 more we so okay there's a
heterozygous loss of function
this tumor suppressor to check gene but
we knew that there was only less than 2%
of tumor cells in the initial fraction
whereas when we isolated the tumor cells
as shown here in orange we see all
actually the heteros are it's a
homozygous loss of function meaning that
actually this patient had a germline
mutation already a heterozygous germline
mutation in this gene and during tumor
Genesis this was a loss of
heterozygosity event turning it into a
homozygous loss of function was probably
one of the initiating events during
tumor formation so very briefly on also
to touch on RNA and it is because this
was DNA analysis but of course you you
think RNA X and L and as another level
of complexity because here you're not
only of two information points per cell
like in a DNA based on the chromosomes
but all the different RNA species will
have very different expression levels so
there it's much harder to really detect
bias from the real event so we have just
concluded as a small study where we've
isolated a tumor cell population c1 and
33 positive tumor cells from ovarian
carcinoma and usually what is mostly
published and what most people are doing
they take the bike tumor dissociated and
straight go on for isolation of their c1
or 33 positive tumors a population or
cd44 positive 24 negative population
let's call it consensus or not doesn't
matter it just meaning you isolate a
tumor cells are population whereas we
have compared this then a procedure to
first isolating tumor cells and then
isolating the tumor cell population out
of these tumor cells which is possible
because it's an untouched separation so
you can do an additional magnetic
separation afterwards again and it's
just briefly looking at it shows you the
results and what you can see here is
that when you compare this to more
subpopulations cd133 positive states to
the bike tumor you see a lot of
difference but you see also the same
difference when you just compare the
isolated tumor sets with the bike to
more meaning that most of these signals
that you get actually
it's just a difference that you removed
all the stromal cells from your from
your sample and actually if you look at
see here you see that really if you want
to challenge what are the differences
among the tumor cell population and the
other tumor cells the the differences
are really minor and if you now have
also all the stromal cells in your
control fraction they will give you a
very big expression difference and
therefore you would lose your relevant
genes just in background noise because
all these highly expressed for example
immune panel genes will just level out
your really target genes and again you
two time reasons I will not go into the
details here but if you're interested in
that and also comparing this message to
laser micro dissection please be aware
that there are several scientific
posters that you can download from the
webpage or get just from us directly
so now coming to the last topic and this
is the isolation of two men saturating
blood cells or leukocytes from-from
tumor tissue and let's start with Sinjin
egg mouth tumors because they are the
most frequently used model system right
now to analyze some immune oncology and
this now is an example for the positive
selection so what we are using is we use
antibodies
there are couple two that are specific
for cd45 and copy to the magnetic beads
to really allow for upon white blood
cell isolation straight from tumor
tissue and these reagents are now really
optimized towards working with
disassociated tumor samples because I'm
in the FP and cd45 selection reagents
available for four years or even decades
however they do not really work on tumor
tissues so now we have brought up this
new product line of to specific
isolation reagents and they are really
optimized to work straight from
dissociated tumor tissue and as
mentioned I will just go on to the touch
the basis here but there will be a
dedicated webinar by my colleague Cesar
on end of May on the optimize workflow
for the isolation of tumors reducing
immune cells leaning too fast and
improved flow analysis however let's
briefly touch on this and I would say
the the most frequently basic question
is why should i isolate my my chills
because I just want to do flow analysis
so I can just get on them based on c-45
and then it's fine okay let's just do a
calculation based on a real-life example
when we work for example with p16
melanoma we inject five hundred thousand
melanoma cells subcutaneously we wait
one to two weeks and then we have two
hundred five hundred gram of tumor
tissue which will give you about 10 to
20 million cells so if you now want to
do flow analysis we will let's say you
start with 10 million cells
v16 is not very well infiltrated so us
about two percent
cd45 positive cells ten percent of these
two percent are cd3 positive t-cells and
16 percent out of the ten percent out of
the 2% are cd8 positive cells so even
starting
ten million says you will only have 3200
cd8 positive T cells in this sample and
then if you want to now analyze a
subpopulation of cd8 cells such as an
antigen specific cd8 T cell which is
about 5% of this population if you just
want to acquire 100 events of your
target population you need to acquire
more than 6 million total cells from
your sample if you run the flow
cytometry at 4,000 events per second
will take you 26 minutes and if you have
nine samples which is really not a lot
to three groups and three replicates it
will take you four hours in front of the
flow cytometer and a lot of reagents
because you have to stain really high
numbers of cells
if you do the tool selection before to
acquire one on the event of your target
population you would just have to
acquire a little bit more than hundred
thousand of the total events after
selection that will take you 33 seconds
and for nine sample it will take you
five minutes of course then plus a
twenty minute for the separation but you
see very fast if you have more samples
which most of the people have it makes a
huge difference
and we have optimized this distill
procedure to really work with all the
kind of different model systems CT 2060
1641 but also other genetically in use
and other activated tumors and all of
them give you a pretty nice and
reproducible result as you can also see
here of course the final purity is
determined a little bit by the initial
frequency but still the fact of
enrichment is always very significant
and usually the more significant the
lower the initial frequency is
it's just one example what I have just
pointed out in a numbers game is just we
we said okay we will not acquire more
samples but you just do a flow analysis
on a v6 into more without isolation what
you see here and we just acquire 100,000
events to keep the time the same for the
analysis so this is the information on
the separations that you get when you
acquire one on a thousand events on the
immune subpopulations when you do the
isolation you see you start with a much
more pure population in the beginning
and then with acquiring the same number
of 100,000 events you can even go down
to small subpopulation like dendritic
cells tomb associated macrophages and
can even do a sub phenotyping of these
without using more time and more effort
at a flow cytometer and it's also now
the time where we want to ask you the
the second pole and so please give us an
answer to this thank you
okay thanks for answering the poll and
so now I just want to give a very brief
overview because a lot of people working
with engineered mouse models actually do
not have five or ten samples but they
really work with large cohort sizes such
as 24 48 and even more animals at a time
and therefore we have spent some time in
really paralyzing and also automate in
this workflow and here you can see the
manual separation where it is easily
doable of doing 20 a of doing 8
separations in parallel with the stand
in a magnet however we've also optimized
this message towards the multi mark
stage 24 so that you can easily do 24
separations in parallel and if you even
have a higher demand for automation
we've now also included the multi map
search when you fourplus in a in a
liquid handling robot station so that
you can just insert your first 24
samples you press start the instrument
we do all the separation for you you go
away and then you come back with the
next 24 samples once this instrument is
finished
so next to the optimization of this
protocol for for mouse till isolation we
have now also recently released the
human counterpart which now also shows
you very nice results when working with
primary human material as you see here
this is a human colon carcinoma which we
have associated and then you see again
in a floater affection you have your
cd45 negatives mostly tumor cells and
inferior says five dots and then in your
positive fraction you are isolated cd45
positive cells and this of course
because human specific not only works
with the with the primary human material
but also with humanized animals which
are frequently used now in immune
oncology applications and this is data
from one of our test sites at Pfizer
where they use mice carrying a human
tumor and also a humanized immune system
and then they are testing for example by
specific antibodies t-cell engages and
then want to isolate a t-cells and that
are actually infiltrated in the in a
human to Moyne human tumor casino grass
for downstream analysis and this you can
see also nicely works with this cd45
till microbe is human because you will
just isolated the human cd45 set out of
the tumor and will not get any
contamination by the mouth cells because
of the lineage specific antibody and now
it's time for our last poll so please
would like to to answer you
you
you
okay and last let's say couple of
seconds I would let just give you one
note because you've seen a lot of flow
analysis that I've showed you in this
webinar and you might be aware of this
big debate about the reproducibility
crisis in research and that's actually a
major part of this coming from
non-validated antibodies and it's pretty
funny because it smells and even before
that debates or many years back we've
decided to turn our whole anybody
portfolio into recombinant the
engineered and he what is already
because that will give you very
reproducible standardized results
because the antibodies are all sequence
validated you only have one heavy chain
one light chain and because they re
completely engineered and produced you
always have the same there's not a lot
of lot of variability in addition we
engineered the constant region so that
there's no background FC gamma receptor
binding anymore and in addition also the
constant region is only one isotype all
the real finiti antibodies the human eye
GG one which of course simplifies the
flow nets because for your whole real
Finity panel you just need one isotope
control anymore
and just to show you the the advantage
of these antibodies when working here
with splenocytes or tumor cells you see
this is a cd8 staining and then you
compare the ria Finity antibody to a
classical hybridoma anybody you see in
the spleen that all looks pretty good
the anybody does not give you a lot of
background
however in dissociated tumors we know
that a lot of cells a priority FC gamma
receptors and what you can see here the
real finiti anybody is not affected by
this
so hybridoma antibody as you can see in
the bottom panel gives you a high
background when working with dissociated
tumor cells of course with FC are
blocking you can diminish this
background but you still see about a 5%
background and you see a pretty broad
negative population whereas the real
finiti and if only no matter if you use
FC are blocking or not will always give
you a very nice and clean staining so
this i want to sum up and i hope i could
convince you today that optimize and
automated tissue dissociation really
improves your downstream processing and
analysis of target cell fractions that
it makes technology
allows for the fast and reliable
isolation of target cells from various
lineages and a generic set has specific
and also combination coding strategies
enable sorting of all major tumor cell
populations
so this I want to thank you very much
for your attention I want to of course
thank my team because they are doing all
the work I'm just presenting results but
they are coming from the lab and these
are the people that really stay in the
lab and do the Riv and generate the
results I want to thank my collaborators
partners and also a lot of additional
Metheny colleagues so thanks all of you
and now I would be happy to take some
questions
Thank You dr. Hart for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button dr. Hart will answer as many
questions as time permits our first
question is which disassociation kit do
I use for PDX models where I have both
human and mouse tissue
thank you very much for this question
which is actually a very frequently
asked and we have compared both kids but
we have clearly figured out that the
human tumor dissociation kit is working
much more efficiently on PDX models due
to the nature of the tumors usually they
are more compared to the human tumors
also in terms of the extracellular
matrix and set cell interaction
components so please use the human tumor
dissociation kit
thank you how much tumor material do you
need to perform a tumor cell isolation
what about biopsies
hmm yeah so of course it always depends
a little bit on your downstream
application so how many cells do you
need for downstream applications the
tumor cell isolation also the tumor
dissociation itself can work on very
limited material so we have worked on on
small biopsies of skin melanomas but
also of other core biopsies for example
lymph nodes so I would say needle
biopsies are very challenging but core
biopsies they definitely work and if
you're interested in that we also have
an application note on our web page
where we really have worked it out and
there's also some exemplary data showing
that and we also give suggestions about
what kind of biopsy needle you should
use if you want to have really enough
cells for certain kind of downstream
applications thank you
what kind of cell viability and purities
do you usually see after tumor cell
isolation
okay so of course that depends on the on
the starting material so if you have a
very big chunk of to more usually when
you when you cut it you will see that
there's a lot of necrotic part in the
inner part so if you remove that usually
that improves the sample in the
beginning but some people are also
interested in the cells that are
residing is hypoxic Nisha's so they do
not want to remove it so I would say the
the purity is usually always above 90 95
percent even when you start with
challenging samples as you have seen for
example in a pleural effusion when you
have less than 2% tumor cells it can be
very high and the viability again it
depends on the target and on the
starting material but usually they are
above 80%
thank you and our last question is I'm
interested in mouse fibroblasts
associated to the tumor
micro-environment
what would be the best way to get them
yeah thank you very much so due to time
reasons I had no chance today to go into
that topic we have also worked this out
in the last two years and this is a very
challenging a population because it's a
very rare population so for four mice we
have just recently released a method
it's our to my associates file blast
isolation kit and it's a it's a two step
isolation so you first deplete the non
fiberglass or the tumour cells and the
other lineages and then there's the
second enrichment step where you
actively isolate the fiberglass this is
for the mouse system for the human
system we are still working on that
so for you therefore for human tumor
tissue currently I think that the best
choice would be to do depletion of cd45
maybe in addition also deplete your
tumor cells if you for example work with
carcinoma by FM depletion so depletion
of cd45 and FM and then subsequently an
enrichment of CD 90 positive cells
because that is so far the best marker
for tumor associated v loss we have
figured out because some of the other
published markets like the pdgfr i find
better they can be expressed on tumor
associated fibrous but we have seen them
frequently not being expressed so I
would say really CD 90 is the best
positive marker but please combine it
with a prior depletion step to pre
enrich it because he says are pretty
rare and many tumors
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. Hart for his presentation
do you have any final comments for us
thank you all for attending the webinar
today and yeah hope to be back in the in
the future
we would like to thank our sponsor
Milton E biotech for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand to November 2018
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live events until next time goodbye